it's good to have you back yeah it's
good to be here
well tell us why did you create
Tattaglia McGraw okay so for those of
you don't know she's a Twitter character
predominantly and I started it about in
last April and the idea of the character
was to kind of embody that kind of
radical fourth way feminist intersection
list woke activist and I did it as a
satirical character on Twitter and then
she got a book deal and then then turned
into a live show and that sort of that's
so how it happened to sort of run away
at my hands a little bit and why do you
think it struck such a nerve because you
started it loss April how many Twitter
followers does it now have oh it did
like 380,000 I think I think what
happened was very early on because I did
it sort of as for myself you know as a
kind of laughs and very early one on
what happened is it started getting
retweeting a lot and particularly when
it because I wanted her to be like a
slam poet so because I was really I
really liked slam poetry well I think
you know it's so bad isn't it and it's
it's really bad and I love I love
watching them do it because they stand
there and they sort do that really sort
of self-important pausing at the start
you know we're like hominin I just got
to get into character and and then they
launch into it and it's just terrible
and and it's always really earnest I
love that sort of so it's really earnest
and it's about important things is my my
truth you know and so I thought it'd be
quite good for her to do that
and so I said that when I was writing
the poems and putting poems out there
they tend to get retweeted quite a lot
and then it started getting retweeted by
sort of more prominent mother called
amplifiers like on Twitter and then she
got permanently banned and so she'd been
banned a couple of times right and then
she was permanently banned and I had the
email saying to Tania's gone you cannot
come back and then loads of people start
kicked off about it then they emailed me
again saying oh it's alright she's back
again so they undid the permanent ban
right
Twitter call it a permanent suspension
which is a semantic contradiction but
but they're not literate you know so I
they're not though and so they they
obviously like said this is the weird
thing about like so she's had now for
seven days suspension x' multiple
one-day suspensions of a full permanent
ban so twitter obviously don't like this
character they're not going to verify
they won't do anything like that so they
hate the character because of
ideological reasons because of course
Twitter and YouTube and Google and
Facebook all of these big sort of
Silicon Valley tech giants are all very
woke and they all have the same
political mindset and actually they have
to do in order to get a job there are
thousands of moderators these companies
who sit there and there's these woke
people who sit there deciding no you
can't say that you should say this these
little Mary white houses in but they're
just trendy and young you know and
they're and they're deciding what you
should and what you shouldn't say and in
fact you have to answer a questionnaire
in order to get the job to prove that
you're sufficiently woke and that's why
they've all got the exact same mindset
so so they so they obviously hate Tonya
you know and that but it was after the
ban just to make the point though after
the permanent ban when that was revoked
when the next day about 20,000 followers
within 24 hours because it's the
Streisand effect so you banned someone
and then they forget amplified so that's
really wise well we recently had the
same thing with an interview we did with
Posey Parker yeah it's very
controversial gender
there we go Sammy what's that um so you
got taken down from youtubers quote hate
speech yes two days later got reinstated
and then now it's got ten times the
views that it had right exactly exactly
but it never works this stuff never work
I don't understand what if you know
anything about history you know that
censorship doesn't work it just gives
gives the ideas you're trying to crush a
kind of credence and and so it's
self-defeating on their part you don't I
mean I think if they if they hate what
you stand for then don't draw attention
to it well in not in why my German is
they had hate speech laws against
anti-semitism yeah you could not be
anti-semitic right exactly I mean
Goebbels was prosecuted all sorts of
Nazis were prosecuted on hate speech
laws and they used it as a major PR
exercise and it might gave them a
massive boost and this is the big myth
about hate speech it's like you know if
only we'd had hate speech laws to stop
Hitler no it helped him it always
happens like this and so and the wolf
race hate speech doesn't mean anything
it means with the opinion I don't like
you can't quantify that and for me like
this is why I do believe that hate
speech laws need to be abolished full
stop because I don't trust the state I
definitely don't trust Silicon Valley
plutocrats you know billionaires
avaricious capitalists who claim to be
good and Noble I don't trust them and I
don't trust the state I don't want
anyone deciding what I can say and plus
people should be allowed to do if they
hate things they should be allowed to
say so it's not up to me you know the
way you deal with that is you attack
those people like I don't want to live
in a society full of racists and
homophobes and the rest of it but I'd
rather they were able to say what they
thought they think you know you know the
current we know who they are firstly we
know who they are you know you don't
drive them away so that they sort of
fester and never be challenged that's
the first thing because that just that
just endorses there won't be that bit
that emboldened them and the other thing
is you know III don't think that's the
best way to do I think any response to
nasty offensive speech is is to pratik
ridicule counter argue or whatever
because that way you can deal with it
but it's trying to shut it down actually
always inevitably amplifies that and
that's why I say this a lot and I'm very
serious about this and I think people
don't take it seriously I believe that
the woke movement and the social justice
movement
as it currently stands is doing the PR
on behalf of the far right it is
amplifying and boosting the far right
without meaning to I think it's probably
well-intentioned but I think it's doing
all the wrong things and it is
self-defeating
[Music]